We walk up to him and he's sitting and Dunn Jr. Introduces me. And he says, dad,
this is Dave Rubin. He has a great podcast, you know, blah, blah, blah.
And Trump looks at, look at him and he's like, yo, I kind of recognize you.
And I was like, Oh, well, you know, I go on Fox. I'm on Tucker Tucker.
That must be. And then he turns to you and he goes, when, who are you?
You were, you I'm just standing there. Like, I don't know.
You go, well, I'm his husband. And he goes, husband, highly good.
You are married. You two are married.
And then he slaps his hands on the table and he goes, he goes,
I want to stand up. I want to stand up and shake your hands.
I think that's great. I think that's good.
A lot of he's like, he's like, honey,
these two guys are married and he turns to me, he's like, you're too.
You guys are too good looking. That's your problem. You're too good looking
Somebody that you have to mention when you have conversations on camera in 2020.
Yeah. President Donald J. Trump. Oh geez. So I was thinking,
it could be interesting for us to share with these fine people, our, uh,
own personal story of meeting the president. Uh,
because I don't think you've told this story, your house.
I've only told this story. I think once publicly, which was on Glenn Beck,
when I did the, um, what was it? It was super Tuesday,
which now feels like a lifetime ago.
Remember when there was going to be an election.
And he was asking me something about Trump and I did tell the story, but,
but basically outside of Glenn's audience. Um, and, and,
and some of our audience nobody's heard this story and certainly nobody's heard
it from your perspective. So it would be interesting to talk about. So we did,
we did meet the president. Uh, so this was,
I believe on December 22nd of 2019. So just to cover a couple of months ago,
it was either the 21st or 22nd.
Cause I know that's the day I was speaking at this turning point. I mean,
honestly, I don't know why. Well, because I remember,
I remember thinking it's the last sort of thing I'm going to do for the year.
I think it's these mushroom supplements that you take in the morning.
I do like those mushrooms.
Your brain, you feel, you know, I'd say you take these like really good,
like brain supplements that are, that are like, you know,
fo for focus and memory.
I think it works maybe because if you would ask me the day that would have been
like maybe December 5th.
Yeah. Well, I remember it was right before it was right before Christmas. Yeah.
Um, well basically we were,
I was giving a speech and then it was announced like right the day before,
or maybe even that morning that Trump was going to speak.
And so I spoke and then they canceled a bunch of speakers and then Trump spoke.
So in effect, I ended up opening for him, which was kind of interesting. Um,
and after the event, um, Charlie Kirk messaged me and he said, Oh,
do you want to meet the president? I said, let's do it. He,
they asked for some info and then we get on a short line of about 10 people.
They throw us in a little booth, we meet the president. It's very in and out.
Do you want to add anything to that?
Yeah. I mean, basically just,
I think we were standing in line with like Rob Smith. Yeah. And, uh,
I was like very,
the whole thing happened so quickly that I didn't even know the present was
going to be there. Yeah. And we were like, how's this going to work?
And they took all of our phones and they literally threw us in this tent with
like, it was called a tent,
but basically they like hung for curtains so nobody could see that he was there
and it was so fast that it was like, they moved us in.
And by the time you turned to like, take the picture,
they were turning you to also exit you out of this room. Yeah.
It was really seamless. It was like,
you shake his hand and you had like a moment to say something to him,
but it was like, you turn in, like they snap the photo,
like while you're moving around and then you're out. And I was like,
I don't even know where the camera was. And then we thought that that was it.
Like we met the president,
we got a photo who knows if we'll ever see this photo and thinking that that's
it. And then we.
So we have the photo and then,
and then Trump speaks and it was the first time we had ever heard him speak,
which was, which was just putting aside whatever you think about Trump.
It was just super interesting to watch the way he works with the crowd.
And he's sort of doing standup.
Well, it was like going to a standup's. Yeah. And he's like in, you know,
he's off prompter and he's on, he's feeding his.
I know more about windmills than anybody.
Laughing with them. Like it's a joke. Yeah.
But putting all that aside, uh, he speaks and then afterwards we,
we bumped into, uh, Don Jr. And he's become a good buddy of mine. And he said,
would you like, would you, would David like to join us for dinner tonight? Um,
wait, I'm blanking.
On her name. Kimberly, Kimberly. She was like, she was like, Hey,
like come over here. And she, I guess knew about me through you.
And she was like, you know, we've, we've got a table for the four of us,
you know, can you, can you join us? Are you free? And I was like, sure. Okay.
Where do you want to go? And she's like, Oh, I'm Mar-a-Lago.
And I have to admit, like, you know,
I'm not as plugged into all this stuff and that's, that's intentional. I,
but I'm not as plugged into all of this stuff.
Obviously I've heard of Mar-a-Lago. But I do not know at this point,
what Mar-a-Lago is. I don't know if it's a hotel.
I don't know if it's a restaurant. I don't know if it's a golf course.
I come to learn. It's basically mine, but I really didn't know what it was.
So when she said it was at Mar-a-Lago, I was like, Oh, so it is a restaurant,
but that just shows you how much I don't know about that. You know,
it's part of.
So fortunately we had suits because we were supposed to go that night to an
event that Ben Shapiro was headlining and we were supposed to be in suits for
that thing. Sorry, Ben, we, uh, we left yet to go see the president.
We go to Mar-a-Lago there's still like,
like an absolute insane security situation.
And they have to like drive us around a small Island miles.
It was like crazy to get in there. We get in there really.
Basically almost strip searched before throwing in the back of a golf cart.
Yeah. Like they really am. Well, it's the president, you know?
And then as you've described it, it's sort of like the Playboy mansion,
but like doused in gold hairsprays, although it didn't feel cheesy at all,
it actually felt kind of classy or old school or something.
And we go in and there's a main dining room.
And I'd say there were probably about 50 people in the main dining room and
Candace Owens was there. And a couple other people that we sort of knew.
And we were sort of whisked into the side room, which is,
I guess the more exclusive room where there's maybe 20 people and our tables
right. In the middle of.
An extra layer of secret services to get into that.
Room. And they make sure no phones, no pictures, blah, blah, blah. Uh,
our tables like literally in the center of the room.
So the four of us have a nice dinner and sitting next to us, you know,
one table over is president Trump and, and Rudy Giuliani.
And they have two other, two or three other people there.
And we have a great dinner. We had a great time, right? Like totally fun.
And Don doesn't drink. But, uh, and when some, one funny thing was happening,
but somehow the way we were sitting, I kept drinking your wine.
So basically I had like seven glasses of wine. Yeah.
Until I realized what was happening. It's because you're a lefty, which, Oh,
that's what it was. You see what I did here actually today,
because this isn't a real shirt. I let you have your water on your left side.
Normally I make the water on that side. And then.
People say, I lost. They say I lost them. I left he Craig, look at that. Um,
anyway, then at the end of the meal, Jr says, Hey,
are you going to take some of your water go crazy? Uh, junior says, Hey,
do you want to meet my dad? I was like, all right. Yeah, let's meet your dad.
So we'd go up to him. And remember,
this is like two or three days after impeachment had just been announced,
which feels like another lifetime ago at this point. And everyone,
every story was about Trump is freaking out.
Walls are closing in and he's a paranoid lunatic. The guy's sitting there.
He had no tie on. He looked totally relaxed.
His hair was a little more disheveled than usual. He was having a ball laughing.
You were living on the moon. He didn't know who Donald Trump.
You didn't know who the president of United States was.
And all of a sudden you found yourself in this room and they said to you,
the president of the United States is in this room. Who do you think it is?
I guarantee you, you would never think it was him.
This guy was sitting there pretty quiet for the most of dinner,
just listening to other people, listening to his wife speak mostly actually.
And it was, I was expecting this like loud bombastic blowhard,
sort of like nothing even against him. It's just, I think everyone can agree.
Like he's you would think he's, this would be the center of attention.
Sucking a lot of the energy out of the room.
Yeah, it was, it was the reverse. So,
so we walk up to him and he's sitting and Dunn Jr. Introduces me. And he says,
dad, this is Dave Rubin. He has a great podcast, you know, blah, blah, blah.
And Trump looks at look when he's like, yo, I kind of recognize you.
And I was like, Oh, well, you know, I go on Fox. I'm on Tucker IDs. Oh, Tucker,
that must be. And then he turns to you and he goes, man, who are you?
If you're standing there, who are you? And you go, well, I'm his husband.
And he goes, husband, I think the two are married. You two are married.
And then he slaps his hands on the table and he goes, he goes,
I want to stand up. I want to stand up and shake your hands.
I think that's great. I think that's justice.
He's like, he's like, honey, these two guys are married and he turns me.
He's like, you're too. You guys are too good looking. That's your problem.
You're too good looking. And he's like, I got to shake your hand.
That's fantastic. That's fantastic. And then he says, he goes, you know,
I don't give a. And he goes, and I don't think anybody else does either.
And then in a very Trump way. And also, I don't think anybody has for 20 years,
no, one's given a for 20 years. And I realized at that point I was like, Oh,
he thinks that I think he's probably a homophobe because I'm gay.
And that's what we've been told by the media. But I think that moment, like, I,
I mean, I knew already he wasn't a homophobe, so I'm not thinking that,
but I realized how much does that suck for him to have to preface that
after he meets a gay couple to say, you know, like, you know, I don't care.
Like, like we're cool. Right. Um.
And then Melania was making eyes at, you would crush.
You like, she was like talking to her family. They kept pointing at me.
So you wouldn't Trump,
aren't talking about like Tulsi Gabbert and a couple other like policy.
Well then Trump Jr. Got kind of.
Wait for a second. So then I'm there with Trump for like five minutes.
And I'm telling him about my crazy theories about my book.
Let you guys have a moment.
Totally fun and interesting. And anyway, go ahead. So then you were in London.
And I went over to Melanie and I was like, I was like, hello.
And she looks up and she was like, how old are you in a very, like, you're very,
you know, pickaxe and how old are you?
And I realized what happened was her and her friend were trying to figure out
how old I was. And they thought I was too young to be in that room.
So it was a whole dude. Do you think I am? And she was like 20 and I was like,
no, I'm 31. And she was like, Oh, you have beautiful skin. And so I was like,
wow, thanks. And I was like, so do you, and then I, and then I, you know, we,
we talked for awhile actually about, um, the friend that she was with,
I think had given money to Hillary's campaign. And it was just so interesting.
The people are at this table.
Yeah. And then what actually the most interesting part was,
which we discovered when we got into the car to leave, I said to you, what,
what was what's standing out in your mind? And we,
and it was exactly what I saw, which was, I said to Trump,
something about Bloomberg and why I thought he was getting into the race.
And Trump turns to Melania, they're both sitting. We're S we're standing,
you're standing across the table and I'm standing on this side and he puts his
hand on her arm and he says, honey, what do you think about this?
And then he has me repeat my Bloomberg theory. And she was like, Oh,
that's really interesting. That's really interesting. But what,
but what was really interesting about it was that he turned to her and the way
he put his hand on her and the way she responded in honey,
what do you think about this? Like, they actually love each other.
It was so interesting to me because I was like, why haven't I seen this? Like,
it was very clear. They, they, in that room,
they didn't have to put on a show for anybody. And I was like, these two people,
definitely like each other, like a lot, like, right.
His gut reaction.
When I said something interesting to him was let me turn to my wife, honey.
What do you? Yeah, no, it was very interesting.
So when we got in the car after, that's what I said, what,
what was the thing that stood out? And yeah.
As it, as it shouldn't be, but it's funny because, you know,
I don't believe a lot of the lies about him, but that with my own eyes,
I've seen it.
You've seen everyone seen those like famous pictures or videos where she's a
little bit, you know, skiddish or standoffish from him. And I was like,
I don't know. I guess, I don't know. It's interesting.